adam ist luca über die lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einer
neuen nicht lachen challenge mit max und
das ist heute somit die kreativste nicht
lachen challenge de hochgeladen habe
denn wir reagieren nicht zusammen auch
in der in youtube videos sondern die
ziemlich diesem vorhaben hierzu müssen
die andere person zum lachen bringen
dafür haben wir uns verschiedene sachen
überlegt und ich würde sagen gefangen
der mit der ersten runde
das ist wichtig weil man hat keine
ahnung auf der andere auch nur
ansatzweise lustig finden
[Musik]
muss man den clip ein länder aus dem
stream die leute verstehen was ich am
gestern auf meinem zweiten kanal ein
horrorspiel gespielt irgendwie meinen
alle leute ja neben einfach die
pantoffeln weil wir nicht weitergekommen
sind nicht eine kartoffel neben die
anderen franzosen und das hat uns
wirklich weitergebracht hat das wichtige
chance bett legen wo ich will nicht dass
du so was krasses machst ich mache da
spielst du weiter
du legst du jetzt nicht dem zug
ich habe aus der dusche gefunden
doch meinen bh behördenchef der lippe
nutzten gestern schon gefragt sind aus
nicht mehr
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in dieser überraschungseffekt ist so
krass dabei darf man einfach nicht genau
ich habe eine geschichte vorbereitet ich
habe die kapsel wieder weiß
eine kleine katze und ich muss jetzt das
richtig scheiße und ich habe ja die
kapsel pro gehabt und ich habe es nicht
geschafft zur toilette zu laufen und
habe da die züge kommen betrieb ich hab
das katzenklo geschossen und dann sind
meine eltern haben das gesehen dieses
tages mit der katze
damit sind hier als gefahren war und
sich gefragt haben die kamikaze ist auch
fed scheißen und die katze
eingeschläfert
jetzt habe ich quasi ohne gebracht es
ist unfassbar bescheuert eine katze
getötet wird man das scheiße was ich
nicht ganz so wie du mir die augen
gerieben oder so etwas nicht wiederholt
aber ich würde sagen dass war kein zwang
einlagensatz landes und schmutz immer
sei das blut
diese runde geht schnell bei mir
[Musik]
perez war max beim sex ich hätte nur
gelacht glaubt wichtig weil du
ausgesetzt sein kann man wegen dem
fahrwerk es bei hilfen gebeten werden
ist nicht schwer
du musst jetzt seine augen geschlossen
halten und aus malta what the [ __ ] ist
[Musik]
zwar kein laden dass sie ich würde ich
habe das so gerne hören dass du deine
stadt.de werden wie das ist ddp shu
zurück 3 nein nein
was nicht nur wegen der so gar nicht mit
der brille angeguckt hat
ganz kopfhörer abnehmen und formen bei
seite ziehen
[Musik]
schönen guten tag ich trotzdem zu ende
gespielt das dürfen wir dieses ding das
ich habe mir mal ihre finanzen angeguckt
ich sehe wirklich schwarz
das heißt er in der wir das verbessern
zwei mal das machen ok hingesehen könnte
was er da rein geschrieben hat
18 und umdrehen was kopfhörer schon
jetzt abziehen und spaß
[Musik]
ich wollte fragen
ob du mir denken kannst
mit
ich habe nicht so lange überlegen ich
noch nicht ich rede
wir brauchen bei immer glücklichen punkt
wo man extrem wird habe ich davon extrem
dumm wir ja
ok du kannst auch mal wieder soweit ich
hab das vor dem computer du hast mich
mal nach guter musik gefragt was ich dir
empfehlen kann
saison habe ich immer gefragt gerade ich
habe noch zu mit breakdance ja schon
dort betreibe ich habe ihn zweimal hey
das ist erstens die kelter das war meine
letzte runde seien letztlich weiß nicht
wie viel lockerer folge zeigen konnte
weißt du was ihr kraft ist also was auch
ich glaube da ist es ist deine wohnung
gewinnt ist es nicht tun springe ich
nicht damit mache ich nicht
[Musik]